[موسيقى]
وفقًا لأحدث البيانات ،
لا يزال فقر الطاقة يؤثر على واحد من كل
سبعة أشخاص في العالم في مناطق
مثل كالب في منطقة زراعية صغيرة على
بعد ساعتين بالسيارة من مكسيكو سيتي ، يمكن أن يكون
الأثر الصحي لعدم الحصول على
الكهرباء شديدًا لعدد أكبر من الناس
يموتون كل عام بسبب سوء
جودة الهواء الداخلي من الطهي على
الوقود الخشبي ، حيث لا توجد مصادر نظيفة
للطاقة ، ثم كل الحروب والعنف
مجتمعين ، لذا فهي مشكلة صحية خطيرة
في عام 2010 ، بدأ أليكس إيتون شركة sistema
biobolsa وهي مؤسسة اجتماعية
تصنع معدات للمساعدة
يحول المزارعون نفاياتهم إلى
مصدر طاقة نظيف ومستدام نشعر أن
هناك تأطيرًا سيئًا
لفكرة النفايات ، لذلك نعتقد أنه لا توجد
نفايات في النظم البيئية الطبيعية ، وهذا
ما صممناه لعملنا وكيف
صممنا  منتج للسماح
بتدفقات النفايات من المزارع الصغيرة
لتحويلها إلى شيء منتج
ولا ينتج غازات الدفيئة ، فإن
حلهم هو هذا الحيوي د  igester الذي يحتوي
على مواد أولية جديدة يفرغ السماد
في التدفقات عبر الجاذبية ، ما يفعله نظامنا
هذا يأخذ النفايات العضوية
المتولدة في المزرعة ، لذلك معظمها من
الحيوانات والسماد الذي يتخمر باستخدام
البكتيريا المتكونة بشكل طبيعي والتي تنتج غاز الميثان
الذي يمكننا التقاط القنوات
مباشرة  لاستخدام الطاقة حتى نتمكن من
الطهي ، يمكننا تسخين المياه ، يمكننا القيام بكل
الأشياء التي تحتاجها الأسرة أو المزرعة
وما يخرج من الجانب الآخر
هو في الواقع سماد عضوي ، والآن
تم تحويل هذه النفايات
بالكامل وهي آمنة  لاستخدامه
كتعديل للتربة يغرق الكربون
في الأرض ويساعد الناس في الواقع على
الحصول على حصاد أكثر صحة وأكبر
للمزارعين مثل جوزيه في تركيب
الهاضم الحيوي لا يوفر
طاقة نظيفة فحسب ، بل يجلب أيضًا
فوائد مالية اعتدت إنفاقها بين 180 و
200 دولار على الغاز الطبيعي كل
شهر مضى عامان منذ أن قمنا بتركيب
جهاز الهضم الحيوي والآن أنا لا أنفق
أي أموال على الإطلاق وأعتقد أن
يمكن أن يستخدم ما يقرب من ملياري شخص هذا النوع من
التكنولوجيا في جميع أنحاء العالم والتي من شأنها
حقًا تغيير الاقتصادات الريفية
بطريقة أعتقد أنها ستغير
قطاع الطاقة الداخلي وتجعل هذا الارتباط
بين الطاقة والزراعة
أقوى قليلاً مع العمليات
تعمل في القارات الرابعة بالفعل
sistema يمكن أن تلعب دورًا حيويًا في
الحفاظ على ريجيس مثل كوبن
لتسريع انتقال الطاقة العالمي جون
تيفت أيريس سي إن إن